in Kyoto today there are mysterious
relative old Japan
painted dolls that scurried through the
streets before disappearing behind
closed doors are they high-priced
courtesans mistresses of seduction or
something more elusive whatever a Geisha
is it's more than a role it's an
all-encompassing way of life though it's
true that some early geishas were
prostitutes the profession actually
evolved from court entertainers in the
1600s the word geisha itself of course
doesn't mean prostitute at all it means
artistic person but the art itself is
the art of a special kind of allure even
seduction the arts litigation would
purvey would be dancing wonderful
ancient dances of the court and they'd
play musical instruments as well and the
arts of conversation and literature to
become a Geisha it takes a lot of
training an evening with a Geisha to
most especially Western perceptions is a
seduction of a kind that is you're
supposed to end up in bed with the
Geisha well in fact what she does is
tease and cajole she boosts your ego she
makes every little word you say sounds
like it you know it came out of
Shakespeare and she's really a past
mistress of that art of making the man
feel good short of going to bed for the
men just being close to the Geisha seems
to be enough
but what's in it for the women who leave
the modern world behind in order to
commit themselves the life of a Geisha
I can do things that a normal school
girl can't do for instance I can go to
see Kabuki theater in these clothes and
go to expensive restaurants with clients
I can talk to people I can't meet
normally dignitaries and CEOs of major
corporations it is hard but I know I'm
doing something that I really enjoy and
that's why I can endure it